[Music]
one of my favorite in the world
very sweet Garth Brooks welcome thank
you very much great to be back I can't
wait to talk to you about this anthology
I mean my gosh I've been looking at it
like crazy look at this okay book and
inside we got all kinds of like CDs this
I should be your Xbox person look at all
that's impressive yes I've never mom
would like that that looks really really
you for doing a collection and some
things that all your fans have never
seen before or heard before so if you
could summarize it in a few words how
would you summarize I just gotta say
innocent it's about the first five years
it's the first part of five parts it's
coming for the anthology probably takes
about five years to finish it but the
first parts just out now and I just
loved it i wrote my part of it guy named
Warren Zane's interviewed all the other
people that responsible for those first
five years so I have to learn a lot
about Garth music actually in there and
I was there every day but there's gonna
be something gonna learn about something
in here every page yeah it's a great
thing about it being the book it's
almost like a diary did you actually
keep a diary as your career has gone
along or no I didn't have to we did that
as you know because you know our career
better than anybody it's the same guys
that did everything same same studio
same engineers same publisher same
players because your night they just say
well we were a family
so all they do was interview them too
and so I'm amazed how the stories all
kind of ran parallel cuz you think after
all these years you'd embellish them and
they'd be but they really stay kind of
true to each other which is pretty cool
they do and there's some really good
pictures in there too but I saw a really
young baby look at your disguise and
like the beard I like to be here to
thank ya I think it feels good yeah it's
like a kind of like this you know Garth
Brooks like that the rocker Garth Brooks
oh really
yes you call it yeah you feel like a
rocker Nate I don't know you know now I
feel good though I mean I think
everything is just one of those times in
our career where everything's kind of
happening right now yeah it is you never
thought it would do that again but it's
pretty fun you can retire and come back
you know now they might retiring days
are behind me they made the mistake of
letting me back in there got to throw me
out now
I am having the best time good for you I
was gonna say the pictures that are so
great in here
determined that you might be a
scrapbooker having all these pictures no
it's just other people contributed thank
goodness yeah you know I told you I
thought that I had no I knew most
everything about Garth being such a big
fan of having interviewed you for so
long but one thing I didn't know is that
Oprah was actually in some way
responsible for somewhere other than the
night well you ready because I didn't
know that either until I read that the
camp Blasi the songwriter on it I was
watching an Oprah thing and it got him
an idea for somewhere other than the
night which was originally a song called
sometimes you need the rain to see the
light that original demo is in there to
show you how it changed all the way to
the one that hopefully you know now
we're just somewhere other than tonight
so um again man just pretty cool story
how things start and how they actually
finish up he was actually watching a
show where Oprah's explaining what women
want from their fellas yeah kind of what
they do to be sexy for them and one of
the things that he suggested I said I
don't think I don't think our character
whatever through that but if you want
him to walk in from a rainy day on the
farm and she's in the kitchen with
nothing but her apron off uh-huh
I said yeah that'll work for me and it's
same real well the other thing he had
well you'll have to read but it didn't
sing to us somewhere other than the
night now we know and you also talked
about in your speaking that sometimes
you have to experience the rain but you
were actually rejected by all the record
labels in the very beginning of your
career which finds you know people are
gonna find hard to believe considering
how many albums you sold that's very
sweet but no I mean trust me there
there's a saying around Nashville the
guy that's waiting on your table seems
better than you plays better than you it
it's true so just the fact he even get a
shot in that town and thank God people
like Bob Dole that just kept fighting a
guy named Lynn Schultz at Capitol who
came up to see somebody else after they
had passed on me that somebody else
wasn't at the show so he saw us live for
the first time and lives our thing and
he was sweet enough to come up and ask
Bob if we'd come back in and talk with
him the next day and the next day we
were signed to Capitol Records so it
it's one of those kind of feel-good
stories underdog King where it kind of
came back and work for us and there's
not a cooler record label on the planet
than Capitol Records that's very cool
did you did you ever get discouraged did
you ever feel like I might not make it
did we ever not almost have the Garth
Brooks that we have today
do you not get discouraged every day I
guess we all do it anyway but your your
thing is what's your alternative gonna
quit nope not fear of my dad's kid
you're gonna keep going so you just get
out there and you do your best say your
prayers and I gotta tell you I never
guessed it would work out like this but
I'm sure happy the way it's going I also
learned that thunder rolls almost went
to Tanya Tucker what what come on yeah
there's no way they can sing that but I
mean we like tangy but I mean that's you
only three songs that almost didn't
happen the thunder rolls friends in low
places in the dance my god how the music
industry works friends in little places
we had on hold on the first record the
first burger was already done so the
songwriter thought we'd forgot about it
and pitched it to another artist and the
other artists already cut it I had it on
a record and Wow
I thought oh crap here we go but it just
worked out everybody was very sweet same
thing with the dance that was almost
mine I was just worried at one country
enough and Alan Reynolds yeah Alan Rosen
said if he don't cut this song it'll be
the biggest yet you never had right are
you gonna tell us who was the artist who
almost did friends know who did is mark
chestnut and Mark Jonas is a great
country singer and he cut the dog out of
it a key
yeah so it was all a kind of a tense
time but their camp was very sweet said
as long as it's your first single
because they knew we had it on hold
forever yeah as long as it's your first
single if not we're guy said I get it'll
be our first thing when it was so just
it became his huge massive hit did he
call you up and go wait a minute I'm
having second thoughts
yeah though he's he's he's a good guy
and always been a good guy to me and
just love him to death and again well
the greatest voices to ever seen country
music so he he did a damn good job of it
yeah so it was alright for me it worked
out pretty well for you didn't it I know
this and there was actually
songs in here which I am so excited
about but that we've never heard did you
record it that we've never heard it slow
but there's a song called Leon there
that just makes me cry every time
there's a song called I guess you had to
be there that miss Yearwood sang before
she ever had a record deal Wow and it
was cool gone here yes she is and then
some cool things there's what we called
a rights which are my favorite things
they rights are when me and you were
writing a song like say that summer yeah
so at the end of day let's go
memorialize it so we know what we got
we'll put it on tape either on a boombox
or whatever
well there's one here for thunder rolls
is on there that summer what she's doing
that much too young
all those original songs raw like how
they still had the tapes and they got
him so it was pretty cool to go back oh
that's gonna be amazing
no people are gonna love that they're
gonna go not yeah you gonna do what they
go nuts what's that what are you gonna
do when your fans go nuts every same
thing I always do thank you thank you
thank you and just because you want them
to enjoy that more than anybody I'm sure
it's the same way with you show you you
want the people that mean the most to
you to be the most proud of you
yeah so I love with those people that's
been on this ride since day one been
through through all the wins and the
losses yeah to be proud of this yeah I
know
and you actually also tell us in the
anthology that you pictured everybody
singing the river with lights and
singing along holding up their lighters
before you even had a record deal yeah
that was the victorious chefs and
they're writing in and she got a little
scared because she thought I was a
delusion estai guess whatever you were
delusional like somewhere between a
magician a minute so the fun thing she's
from New York uh-huh so the great thing
was was to take her hand out of Central
Park walk her out stare on the side of
the stage start the river uh-huh and
here come all those voices and all those
lights it was just it was a beautiful
beautiful moment for the song for myself
for the songwriting partnership and just
that was a that's one of those moments
that you will gonna be one of the last
things you see before you close your
eyes you hear that yeah it was it was a
good moment man that holds central park
thing was big for us fun and every time
you think about it a case you kind of
just relive it and he was
it was a beautiful beautiful time why do
you think I meant so much to you why do
you think that makes you cry
I think the same reason it doesn't the
river just kills me yeah you know and
it's something that you it's something
that you do so innocently you just right
that's what writers do I can tell you
that writers love that right there just
a blank piece of paper they look at and
I'm just going oh and you've got to fill
it up and it's not for any commercial
reason it's not for any money reason you
just do it because you feel that's what
you're supposed to be doing and then to
see how it affects people and then how
that affects you back yeah it's a great
circle yeah a lot of people knew you
actually came to be a writer and
Nashville to begin with very good I did
I didn't want to do the artist thing
because I was in love with George Strait
all I wanted was George to cut one song
about a song called much too young
filled this famil ended up being our
first single and it's funny man till
this day when I hear it it's it's a guy
trying to be George Strait so bad still
am I love him to death he's still the
king always will be for me and you know
that's that's the one goal I never
accomplished was getting anything cut
you know by George but that's that's
what drove me to town was to get that
goal done yeah how we got it turned out
like that when did you realize that okay
wait I want to be I want to sing these
songs that I'm writing would you make
that turn much too young might have been
the second best performance of it I've
ever heard well we were lucky enough to
go in the Hall of Fame
Trisha got George to come in and sing
much to yo whoa seeing the king sing
much so young that was a whole dream
while I moved to Nashville and to hear
George Strait sing a worn-out tape of
Chris LeDoux those two men yeah kill me
so that was that was good that was my
favorite performance of it ever cool
night so yeah this I guess I think
that's what I like about the anthology
it just brings back all the reasons why
you took this journey in the father's
memory yeah that's when you decided you
wanted to think yeah that's pretty cool
I like look at you getting sorry
motional know I love you actually you
know Alan I love you back Alan Reynolds
actually says in the book that one of
the great things about you is that you
are very emotional and I think what he
said you will cry
very easily unabashedly we like that in
a man well I don't know I don't like it
in a guy so it's a bet Trisha loved it
you know what if whatever Trisha liked
me dressing up like a poodle I would do
but she probably doesn't like it it
means you're an emotional guy you're in
touch with with emotion yeah I don't I
don't know I just I just wish it wasn't
one of the things that helps me but it
does and I think it's a gift from my mom
I probably yeah that's probably why
you're right great songs though you got
to be grateful for it
very sweet right I go thank good thank
good as I'm a crier right good I'm happy
I cry it's a good thing um I also when
asked about the speaking of correct
Trish are you right about the first time
that you met her you remember I mean we
heard what that day was like yeah can't
Blasi the writer proofed Amarna becomes
said I've got this girl that you remind
me you guys seen the saying licks you
seem to have the same kind of influences
and we were working with the young lady
and Carrie folks who would then become
Miss Tennessee actually and I said hey
I've already got a partner in this this
is okay so he's stubborn can't is thank
God so he finally booked a session where
he needed a female and a male singer
uh-huh
he booked me and booked her without
telling me and introduced her to me what
would that first day like oh I don't
remember much other than she was wearing
an open plaid shirt with one of those
little like white kind of I guess you
call it muscle shirts now underneath it
jeans that were just a little too short
for her ankle with some knockoff kids
and smelled fantastic
did you find out why the perfume was
there was it just Trisha Ora yeah it's
some kind of real cheaper for EM she's
had since high school so that's kind of
the thing she still wears now because it
just it's it's definitive remember that
smell oh yeah I'm the great thing about
the great thing about her is you don't
smell her until you just hit you and
it's so it never comes before and never
lingers after her so it's just it's
right there in the moment which is the
perfect way for me the perfume that is
she actually writes the indoor
letter on the back it's very sweet I'd
done her cookbooks before but she was
very nice to say and I gotta tell you
you don't even wanna read that I'll tear
up for sure because you talked about one
there we didn't see much I can make
cries oh no let me see wait a minute
let's see if I could make grab would
Heart Ball what she meant I say what she
meant to say was I didn't even know you
could read much less write a book that's
what she but you would say if she was
here about let's see let's see if I can
find a line that makes you cry very less
I'm proud of you husband and it's round
to be a part of the Garth Brooks
phenomenon Cokely husband aha and the
first years oh and you get more handsome
with each year that passes true story I
love you sweet is that the line to get
to it it just she calls me husband
that's the line that's what I get you
that is you put your hands up trying not
to cry yeah I'm not gonna do it not
gonna do it yeah I know that's a good
line not like you there on being a
parent did your music change when you
became a parent to Taylor when she was
first born well I don't think it's kind
of tough I don't know if you do ain't
going down the Sun comes up now as a
parent you know so I think there are
some things that you didn't think about
when you're singing but it's just the
thing about youth you know yeah but I
don't know no there's some beautiful
songs like centum on down the road which
is a song I still for this day can't
sing from front to back
oh my gosh right yeah it's in such
beautiful things like that so it's some
children of the greatest invention God
ever created and what you learn from
them not sure how much did you teach
from them mm-hmm what'd you learn from
them is massive a whole lot edit it's
good it's good and you can tell when
you're around people who who's had
children who have an edge oh yeah you
know you can just tell a lot of it is
it's something everybody right yeah and
patient really does it it takes the
corners off of you for sure yeah I know
and your granddaddy now beautiful baby's
lungs are healthy so it matters and when
your babies are having a baby so you're
scared they're too young uh-huh I got to
tell you she might our middle daughter
might be my the best moms I've ever seen
in my life she's patient she's loving
joyful and I don't know where she got
trust me so you didn't give any life
lesson oh no this this woman was born to
be a mom
yeah she's that good at it and I'd and
no offense to my mom no offense to her
mother I've never seen a mom I like that
girl is and you born to be a granddad I
they call me G G so it just stays
consistent I like it it's great works
grandpa Garth everybody's jumping too
quick she really doesn't know what's
going on yet
yes she does I'm back in the pony after
the front door that's older yes yeah and
where she's like yeah that's grandpas II
wrapped right there yeah and probably
already does yeah I'm sure yeah
congratulations they're being named
Entertainer of the Year
thank you very much seriously though I
don't know about that I getting it back
it was a fun night
I bet it was about how do you somebody
won that award so many time like you
know after you how do you celebrate
every time me how does it become
different each year I think all you want
to do once they give you the award just
go jump in the middle of that just stack
a hairy stinky guys down the road yeah
just wanna hug them pass the award
around because it's theirs
yeah I know because you try to remember
the artist is the last one on stage and
the first one to leave yeah it's all
those other people that are there hours
and hours before doors open hours hours
after doors open setting up tearing down
it's their award so speaking on their
behalf
did anybody deserve it more than them
this year no there might have been
somebody who deserved it as much but
nobody deserved it more than they do you
always deserve it they put in the hours
they did they do you know it was it was
such a joyous night there was some
controversy that came with it to
undeservedly so without with Hawaii well
about that is that you admitted that you
live saying because your voice was shot
from doing so many concerts and then
there was all this backlash which you
know angers me because it's easy there
it's like Beyonce it's like we all know
you can sing give the guy a break give
her a break you know
Thank You woes we just come off fiving
about
well we came off 5:00 Friday night we
did one Saturday we did - sunny buddy -
then you go to the CMAs and they were
sweet enough to let me not rehearse
until Wednesday okay there's gonna be a
game time call my concern was the seven
nights that were to follow yeah going
into Spokane is people pay their money
they they battle that ticket system and
sometimes that ticket system fails and
they got to come back up and they spend
their time getting in there then here
comes getting their traffic parking
getting in and out those people work
hard to go to concerts and I was worried
about the seven that followed yeah and
so I decided to save my voice for that
and again people are gonna do what
they're gonna do if this happens again
tomorrow I'm gonna ask you would you do
through it again no no you make the same
decision because as much as I love the
award shows it's about those people that
fill those seats live yeah those are the
people that you just they're the ones
that give you the award yeah so that's
where that's where I'll put my eggs and
if that upsets people then it upsets
people and hopefully we can all you know
find a place in this world we don't have
to get with each other if it upsets to
be around you know each other so I'm
good did you it was a surprising to you
the reaction from some of those who did
the criticism no I mean I've seen them I
guess I'll do it to Beyonce on the
inauguration yeah stuff but um you know
I'm hopefully this late in your career
hopefully you're somewhat comfortable
with your voice and their guitar in the
intuition I mean I've seen you sing live
for two hours on CBS the wood just the
guitar
oh the Vegas thing yeah yeah anybody
want to step up just knock themselves
out there that's enjoy so just um yeah
and my favorite thing about tonight was
mitch Rosell the songwriter never had a
song cut we're doing the buck and Dawn
one mic thing on the harmony and there's
his face a kid that moved to town with
nothing but a dream that music can make
a difference and he's proven even in
this David he's proven it can happen so
that was my I light of the night there
you go
and somebody came out who was talking
about how incredible of our performer
you were was Blake Shelton and now he's
getting given a hard time for being the
sexiest man alive which you know I think
is adorable and his humor makes it very
effective out let you help I'm sorry no
I'm sorry Blake I don't think you're the
sexiest
Man Alive I'm sorry man
yeah the fact that he's an Okie what
else you need to say okay go humor won't
college humor sexy right won't wait I
know what would you say because you have
made want to not leave you just one I
mean I know you'll say you're not but
you've definitely made one of the hugest
impacts on country music ever you kinda
change the genre a little bit like where
it is is just became bigger and you know
you just really put a stamp on country
music in yeah I mean it would just go
down as one of the greatest country
music performers ever ever what does
that feel like to you when you know you
actually did make a genre bigger oh
that's tough I gotta tell you there were
so many things that happened and we just
happened to be on the field when they
happened but you've been in this
business so you saw what happened when
all of a sudden SoundScan started
reporting instead of asking mm-hmm
there's 20-some artists in the top 200
that's never been that much out of
country music NBC decides to give a guy
a special on a network playing country
music he called all those things gonna
happen at the same time other formats
were changing mm-hmm I'm not sure that
what we knew is rock was still existing
and those listeners wanted to go
somewhere mm-hmm our MB was getting a
rap was started you and people weren't
sure about that so I think people were
all looking for a lot of place to be and
I think country music had the sounds at
that time that everybody loved it's that
a fair enough explanation I got to be
part of it but that was for me the most
successful I've ever seen country music
it'll never be the best because I was
raised on the Haggard Jones era where
bucco wants those guys those are those
are all the kids
yeah I hear ya I know we need to wrap
because you need to go somewhere but I
do want to ask you if you're gonna do
are you going now that you've finished
your North American tour are you gonna
do a world tour well I would like to
take it across I tell you I think where
we might be making the lead now is the
arenas mm-hmm I love arenas they're my
home the same white clubs were before
arenas
what would you take that throughout the
world here's my thing you got fans an
hour limit of crazy they're very sweet
my thing is I'm not sure I can handle
Chicago turning from One Nights into 11
yeah I'm not sure my age maybe not at
all you know I can do it so I'd like to
start looking at how personal you can
make stadiums that people would still
show up yeah I love that because what I
find is music is a collector of souls it
just is and a collector of fun and joy
you get all that mixed in one pot and it
doesn't matter the size of it big or
small it's all one voice in one unity I
would like to see what the next step is
there no matter where it is on the
planet it's just going to maybe making a
more personal show for even a bigger
audience which me nice but in this in
this world it isn't mine it's somebody
else's decision so well your wives and
I'm gonna handle this one cuz I know
we're getting video of it but you
recently gave your six millionth ticket
holder a huge surprise oh I mean you
were like Oprah didn't you give a way
like hard stop huh every million ticket
got a prize right well as you get going
to get more prizes cuz two million three
minutes well to 6 million but the story
of the ticket she bought four tickets
she was seven rows from the top of the
ceiling
she bought four tickets that were not
together cuz it's all she could get and
her three girlfriends she gave them the
three better seats she put herself last
and when Tracy Greenwood the turn
manager is coming up with things she
goes can I see your ticket she goes am I
in trouble
oh and Tracy goes I think you want to
come with me oh it was the greatest
thing ever
because then when I come out of the hole
there they are all down all four of them
down the front row having the best time
and that's who you want to play for
right there and that's six million
ticket holder I think reflects all the
people that come to her
I'll put them up against any audience so
the sweetest most caring loving people
and they show up to do this for me I
love them for that
Shino you cry over her what's that Shino
you cry Caesar doth she was crying more
than I was mother and she was crying and
laughing see I don't know they got like
herd their car was breaking down anyway
so they got a car in a truck and he got
energized oh this was this was cool
Amazon gave him a bunch of stuff it was
so so cool everybody was so sweet and
that's uh it's it's like miss Yearwood
said you can't do it for all six million
so you just pick one and just say thank
you thank you thank you for our lives of
getting to do this on the road it's um
there's nothing better than it I can
tell you that yeah I bet what's so good
you were very sweet no I love to have
you here I love you very much settle
down on that lip-syncing thing it's
gonna be okay it's gonna be all right
I'll try to be okay though